what specifically do you do every day to
make yourself better storytellers to
make yourself better filmmakers I mean I
think that's changed a little bit
obviously in the last couple weeks
because our focus obviously has been on
Kickstarter um but i think it's making
time you know especially because we both
do have full-time jobs i mean it is a
lot of balancing and and you know with
him like he'll help you know to have his
own schedule set of his writing and how
he does that and then for me i do the
same thing you know when i started a
beer and a half ago or so um I I sort of
set myself up and I would like blog
about it so I would do I would walk
different like tutorials online because
I was trying to focus specifically on
makeup at the time I just watched it for
tutorials and then and then take
pictures of that learning process and
practicing and it's like literally
treating it like you would anything else
you know where where I just practice to
help the time and I think he kind of had
the same thing but with writing but
carving out that time and making sure
you you don't just let up on it just cuz
things get busy granted with the
Kickstarter that that has you know
because the whole focus has now been
slightly different but I think you know
to to grow as a writer filmmaker it's
about staying proactive it's about
things like you know just watching
movies but not not watching them with
your phone open or your laptop open like
actually actually watching them and
appreciating them and making sure to be
consistent with a riding schedule set
aside time and associate with other
writers and filmmakers I mean there's
there's no better place to learn then
from from your peers and people that are
a whole lot a whole lot better than you
and a whole lot more experience in you I
mean
that's that's a really important thing
it's just you know learning from
learning from other people um so but but
day-to-day you know being proactive with
those things being proactive was setting
aside a writing time and because of the
position I'm in trying to try to relate
my day-to-day experience to a two story
tellers experience and it's actually
it's a unique position because i work in
my day job I work in recruiting which
you know might sound going but it's
actually it's very interesting to get
the perspective of you know I get to my
role has changed a little i'm not on the
phone anymore but i would talk to people
from around the country who are looking
for jobs and especially in you know the
economy the last couple years um it's
such it's such a variety of people and
they they have such such different
stories and yeah some of them some of
them can be a pain but others will just
you know touch you in and it makes it
tough to see what other people are going
through it makes you appreciate you know
how fortunate we've been even even when
when times are tough but but not only
that here the different accidents here
that you know I start to build a certain
perception of what how people are going
to talk when I call Chicago or is what I
call New York or reverse when I call
Mississippi um but you know then I can
go take all of that in you know
integrate that into into my experience
and my writing too he's kind of I guess
just being an observer I mean for a
writer I think that's obviously so
important in Saudis doing it what these
network to you know I can't turn it all
you